okay now to wolfram
which we can take out so don't worry
do you have any
thoughts on wolfram's model critiques
any
what do you find interesting when you
find not interesting convincing not
convincing
um i
i am not uh
overexcited
by the idea that a simple classical
um
microscopical model
could
could reproduce
the
the complexity of the physics that
that that we see
why do you call it a classical model
because it's definite the hypergraph is
definite or what
uh it's classically in the sense that uh
uh you can view this as evolution in
time and at
each specific steps moment there are
there are steps uh the fundamental
variables which have a
a unique value so in that sense it is
classical quantum mechanics
variables don't don't have a specific
value
um
i think that to
form here
to reconstruct the complexity of quantum
mechanics in full
has not been done yet i have not seen it
uh yet
and uh i
i doubt that one could actually
do it unless i see it in in detail there
are aspects of quantum mechanics
um
like those uh captured by uh
conscience uh spectre
theorem
uh
or by the bell inequalities
uh
which are very hard to reproduce this
way uh notoriously very hard to
reproduce this way
so um
one might copy some aspect of quantum
mechanics
uh
i i haven't seen
the full prediction of quantum mechanics
coming out yet
what about for general relativity i
don't know if you've heard the claims or
read the paper
that the hypergraph model can reproduce
and you can tell me just so you know my
naive assessment
i believe what they do is an adm
decomposition at some point and so
whenever i hear that
it to me okay so you're foliating so
then you have a preferred time and for
some reason that
i'm averse to that because space time to
me shouldn't be able
at least generically it's not able to be
foliated but i don't know if that's if
that's just my own personal taste and i
should or if that's an actual argument
against or for it okay this is your
personal taste
but it's also my personal personal taste
but it's not an argument because
if it was possible to derive
all the
all of the theory
from a completely different point of
view namely not the point of view of
general covariance not the point of view
of einstein but from the point of view
of
existing or special preferred foliation
then okay we would have to confront that
but once again
there's some aspect of generativity
which
has been recovered
well
i i i try to read some of the papers of
the copy of gender relativity
um
you know
it's
if you're something
geometrical and you go at large scale uh
generativity it's uh
come up it's not too hard to uh
to come out with uh uh with the icing
equations um but once again this is not
full generativity
yet and if it is food generativity it
would predict definitely corrections to
generativity
uh
we would be testable
okay
so until i see
uh
this testing namely that generativity is
factually wrong on some short scale
and and and we see the discrepancy
um
i would say well this is a
more complicated way of saying the same
story which it's distinguishable
and it's based on different principles
which are not the ones which seem to be
implemented in the world namely in the
world it seems to be this is no refer
reference frame as you say there is no
preferred for you for foliation as you
say so that's the kind of things we have
learned from generativity so why do we
have to give them up
um
you know let's go to copernicus once
again after copernicus um
did his model
it seemed to work very well on something
one thing it did work very well is that
if you if you make the other planets go
around the sun
uh you understand why
uh the the other planets have a feature
of the emotion which have a period of
one year
because they go around the sun so of
course they were
but the
strongly counter-intuitive things was
the earth's move
so uh some people in particular t cobra
the greatest astronomer uh
that uh you know kepler used his data
for for doing his work
ticklebride came out with a system which
is called the teconic system the system
of ticobry which was intermediate
between
copernicus and uh
which was that the earth is the center
of the universe the earth is fixed so
there's nothing counterintuitive the sun
goes around
and all the other problems go around the
sun
yeah it's brilliant idea if you want
right okay you get the
the cake and and you eat too so you get
advantage of copernicus without the
concept of difficulty of copernicus
so in a sense it was to try to recover
the advantage of copernican staying with
the old
mind frame which is able to fix it
okay
is it coherent yes it's clearance has it
been historically useful no
i mean we would have never got to newton
or kepler or galileo and and modern
physics was that way
the point about capital was precisely
that if we give up this moving if we get
out of this
mind frame
of we are static
we have a better way of understanding
the world
so tico was completely wrong
scientifically and of course we
recognize it completely wrong
scientifically right
so i think that when we have learned
general activity or when you learn
special relativity of course we can you
know by being
super smart like tico arrange thing that
we stay with the old conceptual thing
and recover the same thing with some
some technicalities
but we don't learn more about the world
we just hang on yourself to
all thinking and don't accept the new
thinking which is the one that
allows to go faster the new thinking is
there's move forget it
forget this intuition that my ground is
not moving
so it's the same with this
reconstruction quantum mechanics for
underlying basically classical system i
don't believe
that it's impossible i haven't seen it
yet but
suppose it's possible
but
is it do we believe that this
pushing them ahead is telling us that
really really nature
in its
the death it's like we thought yesterday
come on nature it is death is like we
think today not like we thought
yesterday this moves
is this
what you
in your mind in the back your mind
perhaps think of lee smolin's idea of
time like lee you are trying to hold on
yeah it's the same story
it's exactly the same story
so take the take the discovery seriously
right what einstein did
when
he did special relativity
there was this maxwell equations
um
that seemed to contradict
galilean relativity
uh
which one is wrong
einstein's
answer is neither they're both right
believe the physics right
uh and and and when i say the general
activity he took this idea of maxwell
the fields
and he applied to to gravity so he
believed the physics believe the new
results at work those are empirically
don't believe your intuition believe
that works